what's up guys is Trax and I'm back to
talk about rapper chains and pendants
[Music]
take off this is take off super viral
chain the solar system chain this is a
work of art more than it is just a piece
of jewelry and you could see that
because just looking at it is almost a
galactic adventure first and foremost
you have this beautiful
three-dimensional pop with the jet
stream coming out of the back of the
Space Shuttle it goes outside of that
disc that gives it a nice
three-dimensional look the disc itself
is fully iced it's got different levels
different dimensions beautiful setting
beautiful enamel work on the yrn so you
could see that detail it doesn't have to
be ice there just because you have that
enamel there that gives it that pop that
gives it that life not everything has to
be ice you could see the star streaks
right next to the Space Shuttle also
done with just gold because you want to
give it that contrast and add a touch
those two stars on the side we're
probably added later to give it even a
more pop because this was a masterpiece
the Space Shuttle is flying directly
towards the Sun at the center of the
solar system the Sun is done beautifully
the setting the curvature of the dome on
the Sun and the solar flares are
something I personally really really
admire to the right side you've got the
earth again the detail you have the
different coloring of enamel mixing in
so an artist had to mix in a light green
a dark green and a brown to give it that
earth-like look done extremely extremely
well on the other side you have the moon
has got its craters it's got its look
it's got that cartoony look what that
goes well with the rest of the chain
then you have the whole chain on a
puffed-up anchor link sometimes it's
called a Gucci link stars all around it
you've got Saturn with different colors
in the bands right there you've got Mars
on the top right side of the chain
really something amazing and if you take
a look at the way the links are on the
puffed up anchor link
it's got diamonds on the inside rim on
the outside so all together the full
piece is something remarkable something
amazing he definitely didn't have a
limit when he was spending on this
particular piece there's not a lot of
bad things you could say about it it's a
classic it's something that would if you
see it in real life it's gonna really
throw you back and make a double-take if
someone wanted to make a chain like this
they better have a half a million
dollars ready to spend on it because
it's gonna take a lot of time it's got a
lot of materials it's got a lot of
diamonds it's not for someone with short
pockets you better be ready to spend on
something like this because you're not
just paying for diamonds and gold you're
paying for art young thug young thug has
a whole entire jewelry store around his
neck the most expensive chain and he's
wearing right there is definitely the
tennis chain those tennis changed with
those big pointers those big carat
weights per stone ultimately it's those
tennis chains they're gonna stand the
test of time the baguette chains are
beautiful they're interesting the
different links of different sizes but
price-wise they do not compare to those
tennis chains the exo piece has nice
dimension to it it's done in rose gold
with baguettes I think it's a very very
nice piece it's got a nice
three-dimensional look so that was done
really well but I think the yellow gold
cross takes the cake first and foremost
is a trend-setting piece that single row
of diamonds in the center is a very very
nice touch you got the the pave set or
the flower set as some people call it
all-around beautiful piece beautiful
dimensioning I'm a really big fan of
that one takes the cake on all of us
pieces that he's wearing there so Ghana
has a completely unique ridiculous
modified Cuban because it's got snakes
coming out in different directions built
right into the Cuban now the Cuban is
one thickness it was cut and those snake
pieces were attached to it after that
could have been done a little bit better
but given the complexity of this piece
it's just something that is a remarkable
in it of itself
snakes are beautiful the detail on their
faces the way they open up their mouths
again something that they could have
spent a little bit more time on but to
every rapper that might be watching this
now if you're getting your piece
maith give the jeweler as much time as
he needs you're gonna get more detail
and you're gonna get a better quality
piece if you're working with the right
jewels the gutter piece on the other
hand is the standard drip piece except
the drips this time have pear-shaped
diamonds in it or some people call them
teardrop diamonds but they're really
pear cut diamonds and that's a beautiful
touch with the blue diamond at the top
that blue diamond is a real deep blue I
really really like it you can't just get
the standard layered piece or something
like that you gotta add that artistic
touch he did it with the snake Cuban he
did it with the gonna piece he did it
with the teardrop drip it's beautiful
little Aussie Verte little Aussie verts
got a lot of unique pieces he's got a
completely unique flair for jewelry and
unique Flair for everything he's doing
he's a true artist and that shows in
that eye catching cross piece that he's
wearing that cross piece takes the
attention away from every other piece of
jewelry that he's wearing it he's
wearing another unique and interesting
chain but the piece in and of itself
with the roses and the design is
something that I think is immaculate and
I'm not the only one who thinks so
because that's something that went
around when he released it when I was
released on the internet that's
something that got a lot of attention
it's got pink diamonds he's got those
petals and the Roses the setting on the
inside deeper inside those petals
beautiful the baby the baby is got the
rich young and 4x piece which is the
style of the Dreamchasers piece that
Meek Mill made super super popular he's
got a bunch of Cuban chains that have
the elevated prong setting it's classic
fully iced Cubans and pendants so when
you want to ice out a Cuban you could
dig right into a plain-jane Cuban and
digging the holes and set the Diamonds
right in there however nowadays they're
doing something called a prong setting
which basically adds the gold weight
you're putting a plate of gold on top so
you don't have that gold loss you're
spending a little bit more money and
you're getting a different look
something like this that's exactly what
he has there's the rectangular look like
this or you can have
the rounded outlook that means that
you're not digging holes in your cube
and you're not losing weight but it's
really a matter of preference this is
the style today it could change tomorrow
but he decided to go for the prong with
the extra dimension and the extra gold
weight a bogey a bogey has another viral
piece
okay the high bridge the detailing the
dimensioning that the layering of it
right the bridge that was put in there
and how it pops out it pops in with the
high at the top that's the type of
detail you want to see on a piece you
want to see that artistic sense done
though the model maker working on that
did the job correctly the setter as well
the casing of the piece is beautiful and
when you have these big boy pieces you
want to have the Kuban attached to it
right you want to have it on both sides
so it's not just a bail and a piece it's
a whole set that's what really makes
these pieces something beautiful and
unique that's what I personally
recommend he's got a monster Cuban on
there that's something to talk about
with those big stones we look at that
and you see them in real life with that
piece the first thing you're getting
blown away by it that's something that
went viral beautiful item and you should
be very very proud of that little baby
has a monster Cuban chain collection
those are big boy Cubans up there in the
800 grams a piece on the largest one and
rose gold white gold one of them's got
baguettes he's got the real premier
Cuban pieces there they're really really
nice the wp baby is hanging off of one
of them the wp is the bail that's a
really cool creative bail very thick
very 3-dimensional fully iced on the
sides the diamonds on the sides got more
carats and most rappers have on the
front of their pieces so the most
eye-catching piece little baby has to me
is the wp baby piece it's a very very
thick piece it has beautiful flower set
diamonds on the side of it very very
thick so that carat weight is very very
high it's got a higher carat weight than
most rappers and celebrities what have
you have on the front of their pendant
so he's got that on the side on the
front of it however he has the channel
set baguettes
with the round cut stones as a trim
Blueface went viral with his blue
diamond bandana piece when these guys
put their money in the piece they put a
lot of money but it is an investment
into marketing because when they get out
there and they show it to the world the
world shows them a level of respect
based on the piece that they got it so
he definitely accomplished that
particular task the bandanna has details
it's gets got threes I mentioned the way
it locks the way to put together it's
fitted to his neck perfectly there's one
thing as a professional jeweler that I
think it's missing is black rhodium
which would make the blue pop out the
blue kind of gets lost in the white gold
and if you put black rhodium on it it's
gonna pop out a little bit more rhodium
is a metal that covers white gold to
give it that extra white finish because
gold is naturally yellow and if you want
it to be pristine white you have to
cover it it also comes in black and
black rhodium in contrast to blue
diamonds gives an incredible pop that's
highly recommended but the beautiful
thing about it though for Blueface is
that he could get that done whenever he
wants you could put the black rhodium
finishing on it any time with a variety
of different jewelers particularly it's
the one that he bought the piece with so
he should really think about that and
he's gonna transform that piece it's
gonna go viral a second time Blueface
also got the catch him slipping pendant
in yellow gold black enamel it's
actually you could see the hinge on it
so it does pop open that he could even
set it on the table when he's done
wearing it at night beautifully done
nice model nice setting it's hard to pay
attention to it with the bandanna though
the bandanna is really really wiling out
hopefully he makes that one little
adjustment and then he's gonna really be
happy with the results
young Dolph so young Dolph has got two
dolphins one with a crown
he's got the emoji piece and he's got
the PR e so the dolphin at the bottom is
missing some of the detail that you
would want to have the way the fins are
done isn't exactly up to par with the
rest of his jewelry the emoji has the
nice details it's got the lettering on
it it's got the Hat it look
exactly like the emoji you find on your
phone the dolphin at the tops got the
crown it's got that three-dimensional
look it's got some other details to it
you have the diamonds you have the
setting you have the gold but then you
have the model and you got it do all
three perfectly to get that perfect
piece zwei Li has two baguette chains
and one unique round cut chain that
round cut chain I really really like
it's a unique chain I haven't seen it
before it's something that I should keep
my eye on because it's got the nice
setting in it with different sized round
cut diamonds clustered in and set along
the side those but get changed they look
really really beautiful the baguette
chain is white gold and yellow gold
classic baguette piece not too much
different from what I'm holding right
now this is actually a slip probably a
slightly heavier one because it's got a
solid back not all of them have that
however with these baguette chains and
the jewelers and the things that are
going on you might run into a little
trouble he's got a missing diamond there
that's not to the fault of his jeweler
that happens that could happen to any
jeweler at any point of time of course
the jeweler should fix it right away
for free it's not the end of the world
but that goes to show you that the chain
could be or should be made a little bit
tougher and with a little bit larger
prongs but that happens because this is
a new trend it's a new style and
something might go wrong but as long as
you got the right jeweler that's gonna
stand behind you take care of you treat
you with like a respected client then
you're good you don't have a problem
pearl chain with the sway Leon it won't
who knows how long he's had that because
it's something really really interesting
the sway letters are individual letters
K that could be worn as pendants
individually they're strung in on those
pearls and the way pearls are done you'd
knock them together so you're not gonna
be able to remove them later very unique
very artistic you got your baguette
change you've got or whatever else
you've got you want to do something
artistic you want to use different
materials you want to use those pink
pearls that sets you apart that sets
something it could start a trend it
could do something completely different
that I admire so here you have got a
half man half grizzly bear piece I like
it it's very very nice the Bloods
dripping the half the face is rose gold
the other half is white gold so the
assembly is there the detail is there
very nice the
ears ripped off chewed off scarred got
the details they got the scar that's
something that sets him apart so are the
artistic sense is their big-ticket item
fully iced on the classic Cuban chains
classic rap piece something that's gonna
get the attention that a rapper like him
deserves ASAP ferg got a piece to
commemorate his friend ASAP yams who
passed away he did an incredible chain
on this one I really like it the way the
flower setting is not in the back is is
something superior to what we've been
looking at a lot of instances because
the yam bragini letters are sitting on
top of that flower setting in a flush
way the details on that bowl and
everything that's going on in there is
really really nice for that Lamborghini
logo that's kind of remixed in this
chain he's got it on a different style
chain it's not a diamond chain but it's
still a very immaculate piece and you
should be proud of it because this is
all right so Big Sean's got the rollout
chains
fully iced with tennis chains three of
them going around nice length 16 inches
18 inches 20 inches with the dawn life
in enamel going around in a circle cool
pieces really nice really trendy look
really slick look he did a great job
with that especially with a yellow Jesus
on the end the satin finish on the face
the yellow diamonds and the white gold
crown alright the crown of thorns so
that was attached later it was cast
separately and this is a Jesus piece
that's classic that he probably has been
watching for a long time he wanted it he
got it if you're watching this and
you're blowing up on your first or
second piece don't waste your money get
that elite piece made take your time
don't rush the jeweler you're gonna get
something that's going to set a trend
that's going to be watched for a very
long time